a boy comes into school and says i want
to be referred to as rebecca i'm now a
girl and they do not tell the parents
that this is something that's that's
happening i mean if you can imagine if
that was your child that was going into
school and you found out that for six
months your child had been living at a
four-year-old kid or a five-year-old kid
had been living a double life well it's
fine you'd find out because apple would
tell you
[Laughter]
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
welcome back to the show i am joined by
johnny and youssef from
propanefitness.com how are you doing
very good indeed how are you very well
thank you nice protein shirt johnny
thank you protein [ __ ] protein shirt
micro it is protein it is
it is yeah it's not your protein my
protein yeah what were you talking about
your kurdish hairdo
youssef
oh yeah so i have found
if you if you've never been to a kurdish
barber you're missing out sometimes they
they're turkish barbers i think the the
one i might is a mixture of azerbaijan
turkish and iranian
and they always have some top tunes
playing and they give you the like you
can ask for the full treatment which is
like
wax buds in your nose and the fire on a
string
and like the hot towel on your head and
all that stuff
burning in the background
the full full whack meat in flat pieces
of bread on the way out
what an experience i'd go it just puts
like the standard barber to shame yeah
yeah so chest feeding i found this
article earlier on this is uh from the
daily wire kirstie alley blasts trans
terms like chest feeding calling them
degrading to women actress kirsty alley
slammed so-called trans-inclusive
terminology like chest feeding over the
weekend claiming it degrades and
nullifies women it was unclear what
sparked ali's comment but last week as
the daily wire reported the academy of
breastfeeding medicine published new
guidelines on lactation related language
among the organization's recommendations
is replacing the verb breastfeeding with
gender-neutral terms like human milk
feeding and chest feeding because they
claim not all people who give birth and
lactate identify as female whilst the
vast majority of responses to ali
including nearly sixteen hundred likes
sixteen thousand likes expressed
agreement she seemed to address the
comparatively few critical replies about
15 minutes later i'm a little tired of
degrading and nullifying women and their
abilities she explained breastfeeding is
one of our abilities it's a beautiful
and important ability knock off the
nullifying of women for the sake of
lunatics equal rights does not equal its
equal insanity
a few minutes after that she added it's
our personal responsibility to agree or
disagree with concepts my only point
here today is don't let insanity force
you to pretend like you agree with the
insanity it's part of the insanity to
shame you into agreement
chest feeding yousef
this is a clash between
two different
do you call it civil rights movement two
different social movements of
the
the women's ability to say this is our
this this is a female anatomy and this
is
part of our remit and
others saying no that's a gendered term
and it is not inclusive for
transitioning people
so my problem with that is that
there is such thing as a male breast
if it's
if it's in the context of a breast
cancer or something but
a a breast is capable of lactating and a
chest is not capable of lactating
so to call it chest feeding
is like a
until you can have a chest which
lactates i don't see how it is a more
inclusive term
you can transition and still have a
lactating breast
but
once it becomes a chest then you can't
so i'm not really sure what the what
their original point is to characterize
the language can a breast become a chest
can a breast cease to be abreast i think
i think it's too a breast can become a
chest and vice versa but do you know so
in mammary glands
they're just
latent
in men are they and not used not being
used
yeah so you you know a chest can can
become a breast if you are a male taking
female hormones and you you can form
the and will they lactate
i remember
i had a friend in school
who was adamant that if you stimulated
your nipples for three months straight
for a couple of minutes a day they'd
start to lactate as a man
so he tried i remember he tried to do it
he'd sit in class and do it i don't know
where he ended up i don't know where
he's now
that's a risky move like just just to
try and prove a point to yourself
it's not like it's a couple of minutes a
day but what if it works then when
you're a teenage boy with a with a
lactating breast
chest a lactating chest sorry
well
well hold on because you said that there
is a
if if a man has breast cancer
that's possible
right yeah so so therefore
surely everybody has breasts
everyone has potential for breasts right
yeah you are right with what you say
here there's some of these
conflicting intersectional ideologies
going on here that women want their
spaces protected but at the moment it
would appear that sort of trans rights
trump women's rights so that the women's
rights need to be folded in order to
accommodate that
well so i've just done a video about
what is the physiological advantage that
trans athletes have in sport
and it's exactly the same thing it's um
whether in the interest in the pursuit
of fairness versus the pursuit of
inclusivity those are both at odds with
each other and
while we you know
you want to be able to grant someone
their right to their gender expression
but if that's at the expense of
losing fairness in women's sport or in
men's sport in some cases
you what you've baked what you've
essentially got is someone who
has a
similar background to someone who's had
multiple
steroid cycles or a multi-year exposure
to male hormones
and then is competing
he said that the point was that subacute
testosterone suppression
may not fully eliminate the advantage so
it only needs to be for one year right
you only need to be at ten nanomoles per
liter for one year and that's basically
like doing a 30-year steroid cycle
cycling off and then going to compete i
don't know whether you saw that the ioc
this weekend said that the 10 animals
limit is now going to be changed because
some women are higher yeah exactly
um but you know that there's of course
inclusivity barriers that that mean you
know if you're a trans athlete you face
a lot of potential hate on social media
and a lot of difficulty and feeling
included in in sport and so on so it's
not i'm not saying that the social
struggle is not real but it's um
it's it's about how do you solve that
problem there's there's multiple
constraints and parameters and to try
and match the two is difficult yeah
because you can't even say well this
person has this like hormonal profile
now
therefore they should compete here
because it's the history that we can't
test for right that's really what
determines has anyone done it in
powerlifting yet johnny has there been
any trans athletes in powerlifting
not that
i'm aware of
there is a there's a famous one i can't
remember the name
um
but yeah very similar although all the
famous examples i've seen have been in
weightlifting yeah which is powerless i
don't really understand why that is i
would have thought
to give weightlifters their due their
movements are a little bit more sort of
technical there's more room for for
getting things wrong so as a sheer
expression of power
which would be
there would be bigger disparities
between men and women in the sport of
powerlifting i would have thought that
that would have shown up in in a wider
margin
i'm not i'm not current enough with the
current like the power of thing well as
it is to know for sure but i think if
that is the case i think probably the
reason is that
the weightlifting world just has higher
like you can get to the olympics right
basically at the moment with
powerlifting you can't and so why
it just doesn't exist
i think so i think the re the reason
that i've heard is that it's it's an
assisted lift in the sense that if
you're doing a squat you have to have
spotters
and i think that's one of the reasons
and again like i don't know the ins and
outs but i think that's one of the
reasons why it hasn't been accepted as
an olympic sport because you need other
people there in order for you to perform
i think if you think about all the other
individual sports that's not that's not
the case that's all like
an athlete on their own demonstrating
their ability and no one needs to be
there to help them i've seen people in
the gymnastic double
uh poll or whatever it's called when
they have the two bars the coach often
lifts the gymnastic gymnast up to get
the first bar i know it's not quite the
same but it's not a million miles off at
some point i think so i think they're
they are fighting to try and get
powerlifting in the olympics have you
seen um what zach telland has been
talking about recently to do with the
press out at the top of lifts in power
in uh weightlifting
so it's a it's a no rep if when you go
into the snatch you catch it with a
slight bend and then push out
um and there's he's just been finding
lifts from the olympics where they're
obviously really good lifts and
someone's maybe caught it with a tiny
little bit of a bend or maybe somebody's
biomechanics just have that bend in it
and
the judges have red lighted them for
something that just looks like a great
lift and there's no advantage like if i
gave you the option of pressing
something out overhead and catching it
bent armed or straight armed like you're
making it harder they should get like
double gold for doing that
yeah i mean anybody who can can press
constrict press what they snatch or
clean a joke i think deserves
recognition for that not not a penalty
yeah
but
there's these things i imagine in i
imagine if you get really into like the
the track and field world there's lots
of like little wrinkly rules that don't
make sense did you see the um the
there's a british guy who made it to the
hundred meters final and you don't get
any false start lives anymore
if you trigger the false start that's it
you're out
so this guy made it all the way
to the olympic hundred meters finals and
apparently was was pretty quick and in
with a good shot of being of placing
quite well
and set off too soon and then
some japanese
steward came over showed him a huge red
card like it was like a a2 piece of
paper
just unnecessarily just in case everyone
didn't see it and then he he didn't get
to continue which sucked and like
imagine
specializing in training in that sport
for that long reaching the final for
five years since the last olympics
being like knocked out on a technicality
that is that is as basic as they come
like so i i would have thought they'd be
like oh sorry guys like start again
but to be like no you're not even
allowed that's it you you're right it
used to be that you got
one false start
permission
i think per athlete or something like
that
um
but then they've obviously changed the
rules and he just set off too soon and
immediately just knew but this is
exactly the problem with with all of
these things like as soon as there's a
tiny bit of wiggle room people exploit
it and take the mic like if everyone was
allowed one false start each you know
that there'll be a race where every
single athlete will just be like oh
so
johnny you had covered what was kelvid
like
um
well
i mean it's hard to sort of complain
about it because ultimately i'm fine and
then obviously a lot of people aren't or
weren't fine but it was i would say
worse than i expected it to be to be
honest what's that mean
just
i don't know like you
you kind of assume as someone who like
exercises and kind of takes care of the
health and
i'm not overweight or any of these
things you kind of assume like it'll be
a i'll have a bit of a sniffle and then
it'll go away but i think it's more than
like the total
just completely feeling wiped for like
four or five days straight
um
i i don't i don't know how you two feel
about this but i don't remember aside
from that the last time i was like
sick
for anything
i haven't been ill since before 2020
because i didn't see anyone for all of
last year i didn't get ill i literally
haven't been sick since then
so i think it's probably it's like
temperature right i think it's the
contrast because i've spoken to other
people who
seem to have had
sort of a similar set of symptoms to me
but then also said like yeah but i get
something like that once a year i'm like
what
what do you mean but yeah i think like i
suppose it depends on how often you you
get like a the flu or cold or anything
like that but
when you um
when you like try and train or try and
like you like monitor you try and
maximize your sleep like my throat was
so sore for a period of time like two
nights in a row where every time i
swallowed
it was like
an 8 out of 10 pain and it woke me up
so like imagine having like a dry like
really dry mouth
and then you like you go and get a sip
of water and then you swallow like just
as you fall asleep awake again yeah and
so it's like this cruel trick of like
you feel terrible already and then you
just have night after night of like
interrupted sleep and it just spirals
and gets worse
but yeah it wasn't just like a uh i had
a bit of a bit of a cold and felt crap
for a day or two it was it was like a
full week helped me training though for
one day
for it yeah for a so the the day i
suspected that i had it um
i so basically i went on a stag do and
as much to use and chris's amusement i
was like super compliant for all of 2020
um
when i went on a stag day
to manchester in a beer color
where the like one of the england games
was being played
and um be like sat there in the beer
keller as everyone's like chanting given
how much
i love football yeah i was like i was
over the moon to be there
um
i hate football uh and everyone's
chanting and like
hugging each other and you just start
living like here we go
here we go come on the blues
[Laughter]
um so like two or three days after that
i thought it's probably still just a
lack of sleep and i probably don't have
covered so trained did a squat single
like a heavy single on squat and i
measure the bar speed of all my squats
did this rep and i was like oh my god
that that is the fastest that has ever
moved like of all the reps i've
collected
like thousands of reps that is the
fastest that has ever been
so i walked out of my garage thinking
like i'm fine i definitely don't have
covered and then the next morning like
oh my god and you spoke to your coach
didn't he say that that's like a a
previously used training enhancement so
i was telling him about i was like have
you heard of anyone else who kind of had
this like window where
um as you're sort of dealing with the
virus you kind of your performance
improved and he was saying it's like a
like an old technique where they would i
don't know how true this is but
apparently they used to inject flu into
strength athletes because there's this
window where you kind of super
compensate i can see use of just sort of
skimming over there well the literature
there i've seen
um there's this period as you're kind of
dealing with it where your performance
is is higher than normal but then
obviously you get the flu
so you've got it you've got to time it
right yeah if you get that one day early
yeah if the competition gets delayed
it's like oh
like
there's some really brutal techniques
that like the ussr and russia and like
some of europe use to like not obviously
there's the hormone treatment and peds
and stuff but there's stuff like this
like injecting someone with a virus or
creating an abortion in
a athlete like so getting them pregnant
and then inducing an abortion
to i think it's to like manipulate their
weight or something like that and
all these like they're just like messing
with people's physiology just so that
they can squeeze out another what does
the abortion do
i think it was used with judo athletes
presumably to help them make weight
i don't i don't really understand heavy
weight cut that isn't it
i mean you just you you just go on a
longer
on a longer deficit
yeah it just seems like a sledgehammer
in like the the parliamentary
competitions i've done like at the
international level you realize quite
quickly that like the russian team like
that's their job
so you're going up against like
the british team who are sort of paying
that to be there themselves training in
that spare time
you know occasionally get a session in
uninterrupted against literally people
who not only have
coaches who are willing to do things
like that but they're getting paid to do
it and the population of russia as well
yeah when your coach is making you get
an abortion so that you make weight or
inducing inducing pregnancy and then
making you get an abortion just so that
you make weight that's a level of
intensity yeah exactly well i mean you
just
the uk we're not going to go there
yeah i mean i don't think anybody should
go there really like i don't i don't
like
where you're from as a as an issue this
is why the communists are winning though
johnny because they're prepared to take
it
whatever it takes exactly that's the
mentality that they've got it well i
mean like back to your point about um
like olympics and powerlifting like
the fact that people are wanting to do
stuff like that and all you get is a
plastic trophy and something around your
neck and someone patting you in the back
and like yeah yeah it's fun but it is
just just powerlifting you know there's
not it's not yet a career and people the
the people who win the
the ipf world championships aren't being
interviewed on bbc news you know it's
not
quite the same did someone pull 1005
kilos this weekend
there was this huge
1000 yeah sorry 1 000 0005 oh 505 kilos
sorry
um that's it big dead lift so they had
taking uh
half the whole thing no so from
manchester united there was a huge event
on this weekend and eddie hall was there
um helping to present it
and they had 505 kilos
on the bar so eddie hall had it and then
yep
had it yeah took it off him very
controversially
and then
yeah so eddie posted on his youtube
channel something about a 505 deadlift
world record so yeah you're right wow i
haven't seen it though it's first i've
heard of it did they did they get the
wrap i'm not sure so i knew that they
had it they had the bar all set up which
is a lot of weight like it's a lot of
weight when you look at that well it's
it's too much for most if anything far
too much yeah they should take some off
if they do you know if they took them
off they would be able to do it more
easily yeah i know um like i'd be able
to do it if they took if they took some
off oh well everybody would at some
point yeah no one does it sumo though
do they no one at that level no no one
that does it properly no one that lifts
properly does it sumo there's no drug
testing they're allowed to use straps
they can use bendy bars and big plates
but sumo deadlift
off the cards how dare you put your feet
there
you cheating
did you see the
did you see the eddie hall
uh like the eddie hall this is thor
fight that was going to go ahead and
then eddie tore his body snapped his
bicep yeah
they were going to have a fight like a
boxing match in
vegas soon the end of this month yeah
yeah yeah
it was uh that would be right if you've
seen that you've seen the clip of him
like he's just training and his bicep
just goes
like
so did you see that on the undercard was
supposed to be josh josh bridges versus
dave castro the director of the crossfit
games
josh bridges ex-marine versus dave
castro also technically x army or marine
but not not quite in the same sort of
physical
universe
you must have seen the dave castro
deadlift video it takes 33 seconds for
him to pick up like 400 pounds yeah
yeah i think i'd start josh bridges
i mean if they're both crossfit athletes
like it you know it's going to be a bit
safer but i think when you have someone
like the two powerlifters who are so
hyper-specialized in their sport
and then you make them do something
that's really not related like no doubt
they're going to tear a bite look at the
difference in his weight man look at the
difference in how much weight eddie's
lost it's crazy he does he's regularly
doing these transformation photos
because there's obviously basically an
unlimited amount of footage of him on
this perma bulk where he's a sphere he's
like 190 kilos or something like that
yeah he looks like a snowman looks like
a snowman with legs do you remember when
people started drinking lots of green
tea because eddie hall said he had it
like between meals
as part of his like they were dying it
was like um
it was like grapefruit juice or
something something really irrelevant
that what what did greg glassman say
that
that caused him to floyd in trouble it
was floyd 19 that's what he referred to
the virus as that was 19. really yeah
they didn't post out a black square this
is a year and a bit ago so for anyone
that doesn't know the ex-owner
ceo of crossfit hq um was basically
kicked out of his own company for not
saying the right things and then for
posting some stuff online
and then there'd been a
i guess some rumblings behind the scenes
that he'd done things that people
weren't happy with he'd said other stuff
that they felt was inappropriate in
meetings
and then he was ejected from his own
company and now there's a new director
in
just
racist granddad yeah well they lost like
they lost the reebok sponsorship no that
was that was already lapsed oh really
yeah that was already lapped so that was
already gonna happen um right and to be
fair noble make awful clothes the new
sponsors of crossfit they make terrible
clothes but they do
make quite nice videos for social media
so
swings around the park yeah i know um
what's you've you're on a new rotation
at
doctoring what are you doing now seth i
am on pediatrics
so didn't someone didn't someone once
like some readers of the sun or
something once throw bricks through a
pediatric doctor's window because they
thought it was something else
yeah so so this is an interesting kind
of north south thing i spoke to someone
the other day who was like so he's a
registrar and he's a surgical registrar
and he was like oh yeah i was thinking
of doing peds because like it's the kind
of thing that like you say in a bar and
women love it and they're like oh that's
great i was like really he was like yeah
down south like in the north they just
go pete what's your your pedo and you're
like no like
so
there's maybe a difference in
understanding and
perception what does it feel like
dealing with little kids
it's just chaos because you like with an
adult patient like you can ask them a
question they'll like can i have your
hand please or feel your pulse whatever
with a kid like they're upset because
they're ill and they're screaming and
sometimes you're like chasing them
around and you have to like look in
their tonsils with a with a big like
wooden stick and
to try and do that when they're like
biting onto it and kicking away and
stuff
you just
it's just a bit of an uphill battle so
you have to be a lot more
opportunistic and kind of play with them
a bit and
um you know just
examine what you can while they're while
they're still allowing you to and
anything that's like you know checking
the tonsils that's going to make them
cry or get out cause you have to leave
that until the end
you can't just oh god
no um it reminds me of our friend julian
who
was teaching english in china
and it was like
reception level kids so like four years
old and three
and they gave him no prep they just said
right here's a plastic watermelon and a
plastic fish off you go you've got them
all day
and he's like
right okay he just came into the room
just going hey
toys and they just started crying
it's like oh this is gonna be a long day
from what i know the kids at that age in
reception and year one it's basically
playtime
and there's a transition between year
one and two and then two and three where
the kids have their play time taken away
from them but they sort of slowly
introduce it so they wean them off
the playtime thing and they gently say
okay so we need you to sit down on the
cat on the carpet for 15 minutes and
then you can have a little bit of a play
area outside and often sort of play and
school start to intermingle but it is
weird when you think like if you've done
something for five years of your life
100 of your life and also five years and
then someone came in and said
that particular modus operandi like
someone came into you and said johnny
you're no longer allowed to use
omnifocus like you've used it for five
years and the the central core tenet of
your life has never been taken away
you'd be like i'm i'm i'm sad about this
so yeah they have to fight quite hard i
think well the swedes
do
so they just don't do school until seven
do they and then they outperform the
rest of
the rest of us
so supposedly that the first seven years
they just let them play and be kids
rather than try and like sit them down
and make them learn handwriting and
stuff
and then by the time they're seven
they're like oh i've had enough play
play time no i'm figured
there's also the thing of like
school start time that was in the news a
while ago
like this they start school too early
and kids should be allowed to like get
more sleep and that would act like
shorter hours at school but more sleep
and more rest would accelerate
performance it's just one of those
things that doesn't get changed some
college in america had managed to reduce
road traffic accidents by 25 simply by
starting college an hour later because
all of these students were going to bed
going to bed too late waking up tired
and then crashing their cars
i've got quite a controversial opinion
which i'm sure you too would agree with
this which is that you know a while ago
there was this big thing about officers
being sexist because they are set at the
temperature that men are comfortable at
but women are too cold
okay saying that because men's base
temperature is slightly higher
and uh
okay i mean yeah like that makes sense
it's it's a man-centric environment if
they've set it around that but you can't
get cold easily but you can you can just
wear a jumper if you're
it's sorry if you're too hot you can't
like cool yourself down as easily yeah
well it becomes inappropriate very
quickly doesn't it well that's it
there's only so many clothes you can
take off until
it's problematic
yeah it's just generally generally a bit
of a minefield isn't it i don't know man
like
making everything this is something i
brought up on gb news on andrew doyle's
show this weekend i was saying like
every situation that occurs
is
framed as if it's a small manifestation
of some underlying huge conspiracy
that's going on it's never just
this plymouth shooting that's happened
this weekend is a perfect example and
you have this guy who has posted some
stuff online and said that he feels he's
unattractive to women and kind of on his
own and
this has been taken as
uh what
an individual who has been adopted like
a terrorist group by the incel community
and this is a manifestation of a
cis heteronormative patriarchal
construct that now is trying to run
rampant around the world and you're like
well
you're taking away from it the
individual's agency here like his mother
had contacted the nhs for months and
months apparently saying that he was
quite a troubled
young guy and that they thought he had
adhd and was somewhere on the spectrum
and you think okay like all of this
everybody's life is so idiosyncratic and
peculiar how can you say that it's due
to some underlying conspiracy that all
men are a part of or all women are a
part of or all trans people are a part
of it's not it's just individuals doing
things
it's it's chicken egg you've all you've
seen the family guy color chart thing
it's that's kind of got memed for a
while where it's like a picture of peter
griffin wearing a fez and it's like
on the top it's like the light color
skin shades and it says like
um nice guy with mental health problems
and then it gets darker and darker and
it's a terrorist
and
it's kind of
that's kind of what they've done that
of course if there is a
online group of people with toxic
thoughts and behaviors of course
somebody who is maladaptive maladjusted
and is looking for meaning and some kind
of group identity of course they're
going to gravitate to that or if they're
going to join isis or whatever like it's
the nearest local cultural
group that you can say yes i like i
resonate with that
as to whether the group caused the
behavior or the behavior
just found the group and said yes that's
convenient for me that's what's more
difficult to
yeah tell it's whether like if the
community hadn't existed would the with
the situation have occurred like if the
person was still as they were with the
same underlying conditions
is is the idea of the act
given to them
when they're just more receptive to it
than the average person i read a read an
article from nama cates who has been
researching the insult community for
years so for anyone that doesn't know
about this there's a guy called stephen
davison and um
yeah dave davison 22 shot
six people
including a
a three-year-old and a father and then
shot his mum and himself
and this lady who's done a ton of
research said it's striking just how
inaccurate and irresponsible some of the
commentary by self-appointed in-cell
experts has been made in recent days
take the claim made in the guardian a
day after the tragedy that incels
actively recruit young men recalling the
tactics used by extremist groups such as
isis i've spoken to dozens of incels
from my research and not one of them has
suggested this happened overwhelmingly
these young men find the content on
their own which isn't difficult to
imagine for young people with internet
access that is not to minimize the
potentially toxic effect of a fatalistic
misogynistic echo chamber in which
misery and failure are celebrated or to
deny the possibility that some very
vulnerable individuals with a
predisposition towards violence might
come across their community and use it
to ascribe their vengeance to a greater
purpose the murder of 10 people by
elliot roger in 2014 demonstrated this
is possible but the coverage thus far
has focused on the incel angle to the
exclusion of everything else and at
times cherry-pick details in a way that
feels intellectually dishonest for if
we're going to look at the case of jake
davis and honestly we're going to have
to look at the whole picture don't lose
sight on the perpetrator and instead
blame the entire group jake davidson not
stephen davidson
very nicely put yeah exactly that so
it's the echo chamber it's the the
algorithms it's your search behavior
that
like if you didn't have those tendencies
you wouldn't be searching for those
groups you wouldn't be finding meaning
in those kind of communities so
it's
how how do you pick that apart
there's a really good bbc documentary
about in cells i think they took it down
from youtube i don't know if it's still
available and they find like four or
five guys who
all identify as in cells but they have
different kind of angles and
personalities and they follow them
through
one of them is very kind of down on
himself and has low self-esteem it
doesn't seem to have much kind of hatred
towards women
and he's like oh well i'm going to try
and do
looks max which is some kind of like
insult approach of like how do i take
like except that i am a ugly guy with
nothing going for me but how can i like
maximize what i've got so he starts
lifting weights and taking steroids and
like
and then there's someone else who's just
like a dork
and he's a bit of a self-identified dog
he's like oh well like women aren't
interested in me and
i'm just going to accept that and live
my life but then there's another guy who
catfishes people like he really hates
women and he
sets up he spends his time like setting
up fake profiles on
tinder and plenty of fish and stuff
setting up dates with women using like a
picture of like a male model
at mcdonald's and then he goes in when
they're sat waiting for him
and stuff yeah you've told him yes
before he's like oh you're a [ __ ] like
if it was really me then you wouldn't
you would never go out on a date with me
but it's only because it was a model and
the interview is like do you think that
perhaps
the reason that women don't want to go
on a date with you is maybe related to
your attitude rather than how you look
he's like nah man it's my jawline it's
my like
whatever
i i didn't know so i'm going to play
like the i'm going to play the person
who doesn't know what's going on in this
conversation so i didn't know much about
incel pre you like mentioning with my
talk about chris so
it stands for involuntarily celibate
right or like that's yes yes so
the the thing that just immediately
strikes me is strange when people say
like i identify as it
is
the first word is involuntarily
so like something's happening to
somebody and they say oh well
now i'm going to identify as this so
presumably the culture and
a lot of the like the documentaries and
the stuff that is discussed about these
people is not
simply due to the fact that they are
involuntarily celibate it's the fact
that there's a community that's
developed
as a result of that where people are
then doing things that are not related
to that situation that are worse
they're bound together with this
fatalistic narrative i mean you could
say in other areas of life people do
this too there's a deaf community people
didn't choose being deaf
um the the difference is that you have
far more control over whether or not you
sleep with a woman about than whether
you get your hearing back
and
this is a i suppose there's a lot going
on here but first off you can splinter
an entire group the incel community even
that down into so many different layers
as you've just identified there and i
think that this uh jake davison guy
actually posted on reddit saying that he
disagreed with most of the stuff he was
seeing in some of these sort of men's
forums because he found it quite toxic
and not very helpful there's even a
subculture of fake cells within the
in-cell community and these are people
who um actively try to improve
themselves so there's a
an active disagreement with the personal
development and self-growth world
because that's seen as
being a traitor to the incel movement
you should accept your fate and you
should become one of us and this is
where you get these awful great attitude
[Laughter]
yeah but you also see on the flip side
of this there's these entire apartment
blocks in china
where
single men who can't get a wife live so
because single child policy plus
chinese families wanted to have boys
rather than girls when it came to having
their one child what you've got is this
these huge swaths of men who literally
can't find
can't find women but
as you what a consequence of that i know
i wouldn't have even thought that yeah
like in 20 years you're creating like
yes okay you've got a son big whoop but
now in 20 years he's never going to be
able to find a wife because there will
be literally no women around correct
unless you unless you give birth to a
chad you're wrecked and
the the other side of this i mean so
that's obviously something that's
happened because of a gender imbalance
but there's definitely an attraction
imbalance as you have women that are
able to be more educated richer and
higher status you have to presume that
the fundamentals of attraction are that
a man needs to be in my opinion like
three or four out of taller richer
better educated and more status
you can have a short man that is smart
rich
and well educated but and you can split
it together in other ways as well but
you're going gonna really struggle if
you only have two of those four if the
woman is both taller and smarter than
the man the attraction's very difficult
because there is inherently inbuilt into
women and attraction towards status
resources this level of dominance and
also it it
changes the dynamic of the relationship
if she's the breadwinner that's not to
say that it doesn't work but that it is
more difficult it's like being the tall
girlfriend like
very few women date men that are smaller
than them that means that if you're six
foot one you're looking at pro athletes
you're reducing down your own dating
pool by having that so yeah it's not the
same as selective breeding over in china
but you can see how there is a
increasingly small dating pool for women
that are high achievers and as more
women become high achievers there is a
greater number of men at the bottom of
that list who aren't really appropriate
mates
so that that's an interesting point and
actually a lot of those characteristics
you've mentioned there are modifiable
you know like height is is
non-modifiable but a lot of the other
ones you can you know through the
self-improvement through um
socialization all these kind of things
you can improve them
now the attitude that you described
there of like no we need to accept our
fate we're not allowed to improve
because we we're all in this
mud together or whatever
that
is
it's a weirdly toxic version
of
the the kind of flip side of it which is
we're all worthy of love as we are and
we don't need to you know we are
inherently valuable as humans and all
that but it's so it's that seen through
a toxic eye which is the
like i shouldn't have to
improve myself to be worthy of um female
company and i shouldn't have to do this
i think it's even more than that it's
that even if i did it still wouldn't
make a difference
so it's almost they've given up a total
fatalistic approach yeah and i think
that
it's a a wonderful way to bind everybody
together
because if somebody tries to drag
themselves out of the mud you have the
crabs that cling on from the bottom of
the bucket it's the crab mentality but
the whole
point is that if you don't bring
anything to the table
then how can you expect
anyone to
be interested it's like the opposite of
the self-improvement self-development
world right of like i'm just gonna if i
just identify with a group of people who
say well
we're [ __ ] regardless
then
you it's it's it's it's permission to
not try and change the situation because
as you were saying like three if is it
three of the four were modifiable or
improvable yeah
if that's the framework you're playing
in then
just improve those things
i think it's important
take some growth i think that
admitting that there's a potential for
hope
can be quite painful whereas just
relinquishing any hope
is is the easiest place that's why when
people have missing children
a lot of the time they would actually
probably after 10 years or 20 years they
would soon find out that they were dead
then continue going on with that open
loop because they just want to close off
that situation and by closing off the
potential for improvement you actually
think well there's no hope at least now
i know what to expect i can predict what
happens in the future and it's more
misery and
aloneness well the like the definition
of the top of google says that
it's just a it's blaming women for a
lack of sexual activity so
by very
definition it's like failing to accept
responsibility for the situation and if
you have hope then it's like well i have
to change somebody else
i have to change other people in order
for this to improve rather than well i
can just change myself that being said
women are the sexual gatekeepers and men
are the sexual protagonists
so a couple of suggestions would be
go gay
but no one says no
in the
game turn gays
just turn gay like or like does
gay men have loads more sex
but i mean
okay i realize that's a tongue-in-cheek
suggestion but do you think that that
would be an effective an effective
solution well that implies that like you
can just alter your preferences are you
saying johnny that some people may not
just be able to alter their preferences
like a fashion choice
no i said it it assumes it i didn't say
this it
can't be done
well
so something i would recommend for
background of anyone listening is
have a look at some of the like
in-cell subreddits in fact it might have
even been
a bunch of them because a bunch of them
have been removed but you see if you go
to our slash men's rights
there's
sort of echoes of that that would have
gone somewhere yeah yeah there's little
echoes of it so you're encouraging
people to type into google
something that is a
fairly extremist
even term that is then going to feed
more of that sort of information back to
that person well reddit isn't optimized
in that way so reddit's actually quite
safe like that
yeah yeah fair point
that point so just type it into your
browser and then search within reddish
but it's yeah it it's worth having a
look and seeing that we're not
caricaturing the viewpoints here like it
is very much
the the tone in
what they're saying
yeah scary stuff and they they kind of
revere is it what do you say elliot
rogers yeah they hold him up as like a a
prophet yeah correct yeah they literally
say there was this screenshot
of a guy who did a shooting in america
and just beforehand
he was talking about how i like all hail
our hero elliot rodger or mr roger or
something like that
referring to that so yeah you do get
this um
it's so insular man
and
yeah it's difficult it is difficult
right because you have the the bottom 80
of men are competing for the bottom 20
of women on tinder and the top 80 of
women are competing for the top 20 of
men so like this imbalance this
hypergamous imbalance that you have in
attraction
it does lead to
men that can't get a date and women that
struggle to find a man that they're
attracted to like this is just
this is one of the challenges
you were saying that these these
subreddits have been closed so that
do you think that this will like
move towards a world where
like predictive algorithms will be able
to forecast this kind of
violent behavior that that comes off the
back of these
days in fact speaking of which
how do you feel about apple's new move
have you heard about this
that they are now doing
server-side scanning of your images
to see if it matches with any child
abuse images and
and then reporting it to the authorities
and i think it's been under fire not
only because apple have now stepped in
from being private company to law
enforcer which is you know arguably
outside of their their remit their
counter argument is well if you're
holding on our servers we it's our
business to make sure that we've not
you've not put dodgy stuff on our
servers
but
it's the it's more that it's a slippery
slope potentially for well if you have
the technology in place you could very
much change the database of stuff that
you're checking it against
to anything that the local
government doesn't
like
i think the biggest problem with it is
like well firstly
it feels slightly hypocritical that a
lot of the changes in ios 14 where we
don't trust
google facebook or any of these other
big companies to manage your data so
we're going to allow you to say well no
they can't do that but we can't aside
from no longer using an apple device we
can't opt out of this and i know like
the source reason is right like it's a
valid reason of what it's a very it's a
very clever valid reason because it's
like oh you're not in favor of this that
must mean that you're probe child abuse
then it's
like coming from a like constantly
surfing the edge of the algorithms of
these these big companies from an
advertising perspective like the number
of things that they when an algorithm is
trying to make a decision the number of
like false positives it spots in
something
that's what's most worrying
when it's like it's up to something to
just scan a photo library
and if it sees something that it deems
to be illegal even if it's completely
not illegal
it can be reported to the authorities
and you've just got to deal with the
backlash shouldn't you say that it gets
passed up to a human operator that's
going to check first
supposedly but then
i mean the same thing applies with the
imessage but it doesn't go to i think it
just goes straight to so within our
message if you have an icloud account
that's registered as under 12 or under
16
and you send
and like a picture that could be seen
could be picked up by the neural network
as a naked picture
it'll blur out the picture for the
recipient and it'll inform the family of
the sender you are kidding me
so so if you send a nude at 16 years old
it might be 12 or 13. okay
but yeah the point stands that it will
tell your family so the risk there is
that it could be apples
it could be the blood on apple's hands
if let's say it's a pakistani gay 12 or
13 year old whose family do an honor
killing because they've been
informed that they've sent a nude [ __ ]
that's it's
a scary
potential as soon as you change yourself
from being a communicator to being a
policer
everything
you have to try and plug an awful lot of
holes in the bottom of the boat and
doing them individually on a
case-by-case basis like this like i
never thought of that the equivalent
would be probably if you're in an
orthodox jewish community and they found
out that you were homosexual
that's it like you're you're out you're
out of i mean you're not dead but you're
never going to be allowed back into that
community again it's the other side of
it is it's placing
a lot of emphasis on like the algorithm
spotting these things so it needs one
instance of it like what is positive
well false positive or like maybe it it
it identifies differently with like skin
tone skin color like lots of different
things and suddenly one instance isn't
picked up and something happens off the
back of it
like it just needs one failure
for the whole thing
to be to fall apart so it's got a if
they're going to say like this is what
we're doing
it needs a 100 percent
capture rate we were doing fine without
it like
it's a bit i i think it it could
so like i don't know how you two feel
about it but i think even though
obviously i'm not i'm not worried about
them seeing something illegal in my
photos like i don't really like the idea
of it
because it's a it's an invasion thing
isn't it like ever they're going to read
and look at everything on my phone so
the sad thing is they already have this
capacity it's just that they haven't
turned it on and it's us becoming aware
of the fact that they can do it the same
as when people said i can't believe that
my alexa's been recording things
how the [ __ ] do you think it knows when
you say hey alexa like yeah what do you
think it was doing like it's constantly
listening the only difference is the
fact that they've recorded it and saved
it somewhere so like part of the
incredulity that comes with it is just
like look presume that all tech
companies have all access to everything
that you do and they simply haven't
decided to flip the switch to be able to
look at it
yeah well they have and they just don't
talk about it publicly like it's a good
way of looking at it if you say okay i
have purchased a device that has a
built-in microphone and camera and voice
recognition and transcription capability
and uploading capacity with very high
speed and all these like features like
if this device does that you'll be like
well what could it potentially do
if i
didn't want it to so i think that the
difference here is them is apple
openly saying we are going to report
these this information to the
authorities isn't it like i think we i i
already feel like everything i type into
whatsapp or every gmail email or every
facebook messenger conversation or
whatever
is read by something
but at least they don't they don't
publicly say if you say this word uh
yeah you're gonna have it yeah
you're gonna have some consequence to
deal with that like we're not gonna be
involved in we're just going to pass
your information on and if we're right
or whatever then so that's not you to
deal with that actually has given rise
to the theory that apple
that it wasn't really apple's decision
because from a profit perspective i'm
not sure why that why they would launch
something like this and so some people
have suggested claimed that it could be
apple have been strong armed by
some government to say like oh you need
to launch this and subject to a gag
order it just feels so like the other
thing they're doing in ios 15 is is
they're removing like
um
the ability for for companies like
convertkit an active campaign all these
things to say that someone's opened an
email right which like
is arguably really damaging all these
businesses that don't have ill intent at
least as far as i know right so what
have to be the reason for protecting
people from knowing whether or not
it's a privacy thing right the whole
thing's a privacy thing so you can now
say that facebook
google all these other third-party
companies can't track you on ios 14 and
you're now going to be able to say that
you can create single use which is
youtube's dream you can write like
single instance email addresses within
within within apple so that you just
someone receives a promo email once and
then you're not they're not on an email
list which affects so many businesses
right and it's all in the name of
privacy but at the same time they're
saying we're gonna look at all your
photos
it just doesn't like
i know that the agendas are different
behind the two decisions but it feels
very hypocritical of like well we own
the hardware so we have one set of rules
but everybody else it's like
difficult to take this sort of puritan
uh
talking point
about safety and security and you can
own your own data whilst at the same
time doing something that's completely
like analog opposite yeah yeah yeah yeah
um have you been looking at this
afghanistan afghanistan situation
because i tweeted yesterday saying i i
don't really know
what
are people complaining about the fact
that we've pulled out should we have
never been there in the first place is
there an argument that we should have
left troops on site i think 400 and
400 and something british troops have
been killed there since we landed
and
there's
everybody seems to have an opinion and
nobody seems to have a solution
we're operating on incomplete
information as well
i think many of the big global events
over the last 30 years
there's always going to be partial
information that's not public and
maybe is leaked and released over the
next 20 or 30 years by the time it's
irrelevant
but
yeah it seems like a kind of
i suppose you have to pull a stop loss
at some point and say ah you know what
we can't help with this but then
the consequence is as soon as you do
there's this big like
the dam breaks and everything floods
back and we're seeing that in the photos
the one you sent before of like
people sat on the the wing of an
airplane or like the traffic charms or
climbing up into the airport
dude there's a i can't remember the name
of the plane it's a american military
plane like a c
c 60 or something like a big just it's a
hanger it's a huge lorry out the back
with nothing in it and they managed to
fit 800 people
into one of these
compartments out the back absolute
ryanair style yeah
yeah it's still better quality than
ryanair
um yeah and then i saw a video of a
plane
moving down the runway it didn't look
like it was about to it wasn't at
takeoff speed but there was people
holding on to the wings
while it's taking off well i don't know
if it was it wasn't at takeoff speed and
there was a lot of people running in
front of it but surely you die
sure you're not lasting you're not
lasting
yeah well you'd have to have really good
what if you use straps because johnny
reckons that straps are cheating we'd
need a strap that went around the wing
yeah so just one of those little
i think i think they'd run into like
oxygen altitude problems yeah
temperature
and like you need a lot of chalk
you would need a lot of sugar to get
maybe even a belt to be honest together
i don't think the belt would help knee
sleeves
[Laughter]
yeah it'd be the guy with knee sleeves
who stays on everyone else we're like
did you see um
i swear it was
biden that tweeted a couple of months
ago saying this will not be a last
chopper out of saigon moment and
someone's quote tweeted it with a photo
of a helicopter landing on the top of
the us embassy in the middle of
afghanistan to pick some people up and
take them away
hell
yeah i mean it looks fairly horrendous
doesn't it
every image everything that's coming out
of it but as you said like
it how do you form an opinion on
something when you already see like the
the headlines
you see like the filtered view of it
johnny are you saying that the internet
is supposed to take their time
and fully research your problem before
they actually decide to commit to making
making a comment about it don't be
ridiculous i know
how dare i
every time you say are you saying i'm
like oh my god he's gonna cathy newman
i'm getting counted here
well i watched the
um the the snippet of your interview on
camera
gb news where there was a segment i saw
involves a lot of are you sayings going
in your direction correct just sort of
like leaning on the surface
yeah that was andrew was trying to
stitch me up so i'm passing the parcel
onto you today
yeah he um they brought up as well on
that about the snp instructing schools
that children should be able to decide
their gender without parental consent
and that a teacher must comply with that
child's wish children as young as four
can change their names and gender at
school without parental consent
teenagers of opposite sexes can share
rooms on residential trips likewise for
those who identify something else can
share a room with others who identify
differently gender neutral toilets and
the snp have become so obsessed with
trans right that safeguarding is now a
nightmare um
i mean
my business partners kids
often identify as astronauts in the
morning and then train drivers in the
afternoon and
a rocket man before before dinner so
that's it isn't it it's like
i i mean i can't really remember being
that age but like i can't remember being
like 17 and still not really feeling
that like i would trust a 17 year old
version of me to make permanent any
decision yeah so
i think if there's no if you can just do
whatever you want at that age and
there's no like guidelines or guard
rails
if there's permanent consequences it may
be a little bit unfair i think yeah ray
dalio talks about this where like the
permanence of a decision is
proportional to how long you should
spend on it and how reversible the
decision is
but
again it's it's it's this balance
between someone's right to gender
expression and the potential for that
right to be exploited by
characters who
want to and there isn't an easy solution
like the was there not that guy who went
to prison
for some kind of series of
sexual assaults or rapes or something
and then he said i want to go in the
women's prison
and then he just continued offending
identified as a woman and then yeah
moved across i mean i don't think that
that's a rare
that's a particularly rare story anymore
obviously children that this isn't a
permanent consequence you know to to
steal them on the other side it's not a
permanent consequence to change their
gender expression or to change their
name and do things like that but at four
years old allowing the child to do
anything you know if the child was late
to school the parents would probably be
told but changing their gender
expression in their name and it's like i
i think one of the concerns that some
people have is that it indulges and
perhaps actually encourages in children
something which at that age is so
confusing and maladaptive that it can
put them down
paths that's a little bit difficult so
andrew doyle talks a lot he's a gay man
and he talked about the fact that he
didn't do sports he didn't do football
at school i think he maybe even did sort
of dance or ballet or something and he
was really into acting like he would
have absolutely been classed as probably
a a future female
under this particular a particular sort
of world view and it is kind of a
rehabilitated homosexual hatred in a way
that some of it is that a butch girl or
a
female as like a girly bloke
that these can't be seen as someone that
might actually be homosexual it's like
no you're heterosexual but in the wrong
body
yeah but there's not much downside i
mean if if they're four years old you
say do you want to do you want to stay
with the girls or stay with the boys i
think
there's not too much of a potential risk
i think when it's 13 14 like potentially
more of a risk in terms of
like sexual age but then
for like
you know
there's an argument to say like
let them experiment let them do what
they want because you know if you say to
a four-year-old kid
do you want a dinosaur for breakfast
yeah yeah i do but then equally as you
say if there's a permanent thing like
would do you want to shoot the teacher
like yes like obviously you don't mean
it but if you allowed them to carry that
out then
a few years later they'd be like i wish
i hadn't she hadn't let me shoot that
teacher because but even
there's a difference between
posing the question to them and it
allowing it to naturally arise
and i think like as you say like if you
if you say do you want to do this at
four years old you maybe just don't have
the the information or the life
experience to to evaluate that decision
so you might just say yes or no you know
like it's hard to know i can't remember
what it's like to be full
i don't imagine very many people can
but yeah like if something naturally
arises and like that's a request
i think it's that that to me anyway
feels different to what about not
telling the parents
as
if they ask them do you want to do this
or not so
yes a boy comes into school and says i
want to be referred to as rebecca i'm
now a girl and they do not tell the
parents that this is something that's
that's happening i mean if you can
imagine if that was your child
that was going into school and you found
out that for six months
your child had been living it a
four-year-old kid or a five-year-old kid
had been living a double life well it's
fine you'd find out because apple would
tell you
get a notification from my family
the school would try not to pass the
information off but they'd have no
choice yeah because you're alexa the
google homepod would have been listening
in and would have sent an alert that
your child had changed their icloud name
yeah
google won't know like google won't be
able to see a search history but apple
will just send a text to the parents so
it's neither here nor there fine yeah it
seems like a
yeah
i would want to know as the parent
but i guess like it depends on because
you have a right to know as a parent
it feels like the answer the natural
answer to that is yes i suppose
because so the
metric that they use in
medicine if you have say a
13 year old
girl who's saying i'm sexually active
and it's whether you inform the parents
or not is you have to make a
decision as to whether they are gaelic
competent which is based on an old
legal case
of you know gillig versus whatever
and it's
is this person despite the fact that
they are below the age of consent do
they still have the
necessary ability to
weigh up the consequences of their
decisions within agency almost free will
yeah
but you you would you know
you would want to i mean again this is
assuming that like
there's the right intentions there and
the information's received well like you
would want to provide the relevant
support as a parent to that person
and to to not have the information and
to go on assuming that that's not
happening
i think like takes the
takes something off the parents to be
able to support their child correctly
you're the guardian right there's one
that's supposed to be the caregiver
you're
liable for whether or not i mean people
look at fat kids
and blame it on the parents for feeding
them the wrong food
the only reason that like if if your
children were able to get fat and
physically not show it and you could be
culpable for the fact that internally
they were getting really really fat
like this like gatekeeping community
gatekeeping information from the parents
about something which is absolutely
crucial to the child's well-being like
i don't know again it kind of comes back
to this intersecting ideologies thing
here that you have certain parts of
certain
um world views that just don't agree
with each other
and
given the fact that the lgbt community i
think i i it wouldn't surprise me if
you're going to see more challenges up
against parenting because you're going
to have a lower proportion of parents
represented within that community
and you think well i mean
where do you go from there like it's a
real challenge
and yeah and you know you've made a
comparison of being secretly fat and i i
realize i'm also conflating sexual
preference with gender preference and
that they're not the same and you know
there's different ages at which that
becomes the parents problem and and the
child's problem and so on so
it's a it is just a very
difficult one to navigate and i don't
think you can really set like a you know
between this age and this age because it
does just depend on
consent and
what the relationship is and whether
someone has the
capacity to make a decision about
themselves
should apple be reporting like
potentially dangerous search history of
children to their parents oh like
type stuff
for example yeah like linking out i
suppose linking together what we've just
been talking about like
if the if these things if the parent is
supposed to be the the guardian of
you know encouraging the right of the
wrong decisions and you see a flag like
that should that be reported
again it's a challenge man like at what
point
where does anonymity or where are you
guaranteed anonymity and where should it
where should it exist where should the
privacy
where should the privacy exist for that
i mean i had seth stevens davidowitz on
who's a data analyst and he'd done all
of these different correlations to do
with google search history
and he was able to identify
it was him that was able to find out
where covid cases were going to spike
seven days before they did by looking
for search
the search history aggregated so this is
totally anonymized
of what people are looking for why have
i lost my sense of smell why am i so hot
when i sleep at night
and he was he was able to predict seven
days out
where the highest cases were so that was
the quickest route to be able to work
out what was going on he was also able
to see um locations where there were
higher rates of suicide based on some of
the search histories like how how to
deal with depression
what to do if you're feeling suicidal
all of these aggregated searches were
correlated with higher levels of
suicidality within a particular location
it's a whole new
level isn't it where like the captures
and they can pick up early signs of
parkinson's from the tremor in your mass
now do they report that to the health
insurance company like does the
insurance company have a right to know
before you do
do they have the right to even tell you
because they've diagnosed a problem that
you didn't actually
go and ask them to but then one side of
that like it's it's anonymous data isn't
it it's trends of
search terms by volume in newcastle
versus this person has exhibited this
behavior
it's a very different like i don't mind
i don't mind my search history being
used as ways to like improve things
but if i'm going to experience like
because i was a bit
shaky with my mouse when i was clicking
on the
which of these squares have a
i have a traffic light in them like and
i'm your premium goes up yeah i'm creepy
yeah like i don't know how i feel about
that versus the it's weird isn't it
because of information what we're
relying on
is
a level of opaqueness between what the
insurance company knows about us and
what is actually happening about us and
there is a degree of game playing going
on here like if you are at risk for
parkinson's or if you are have like
early parkinson's uh like onset
um
symptoms then
it's probably quite right that the
insurance company is supposed to know
about it the fact that the current
level of finesse with which they can see
your entire sort of medical makeup isn't
there i mean you know what what's the
job of the insurance company is the job
of the insurance company to make
premiums based on information that
they're given or make premiums based on
your health
have you guys seen or have we discussed
coded bias on netflix no but i've had an
interview with the guy who did some
research for it right you should watch
it because it talks about like
because ultimately the problem here is
there is
ai processing this information
a large scale and it's like we're
relying on fair processing we're relying
on like an algorithm to make a decision
that's going to influence like can we
get a mortgage
can we get a credit card what is our
insurance costing based on some things
that
like all the way down to
how you move your mouse
or what you search on google and you
know is it fair for those things is it
fair for the code to have a bias
basically and how do you police that
if something's just being if something's
happening constantly
how do you like should a human
with emotional bias come in and insert
their bias on top of the code bias
or like how do you manage like it could
potentially all be fine
or it could potentially all be
catastrophic
and i feel like all technology like all
the precipices of technology that we're
approaching now are subject to that like
it could all be great or it could all
kill us all yeah
and you've got to make a decision based
on no information
just hope for the best yeah i had i had
stuart russell on the show the guy that
wrote the book on artificial
intelligence and his most recent one
human compatible is about the control
problem the scariest thing that i
learned from that was that the social
media content selection algorithms the
ones that literally tried to get click
uh click throughs and time on site
that's all that they're bothered about
get people on and keep them on that's
all that they were asked to optimize so
what they want is to be better able to
predict the preferences of the users if
they can put content in front of them
that they're more likely to click on and
more likely to stay on then it has
achieved its goal there's actually two
ways that the algorithm it would appear
there's two ways the algorithm could
achieve that first one is to become
better at predicting what the users want
the second one is to manipulate the
user's preferences to make them more
predictable
and it turns out that social media
content feed selection algorithms have
been doing the second one a lot more so
when everybody says about oh you've got
this increasing sort of these extremist
views on the internet everybody's far
left or everybody's far right or
everybody's pro this or not that
and this is because of echo chambers
it's because you have these very sort of
siloed communities in which people only
hear one point of view well yeah that's
part of it but another part of it is
that the algorithms almost have like a
an email trigger sequence a several year
email trigger sequence that takes
somebody that clicks on a thing and then
slowly tries to push their preferences
because if you're out on the extremes
you're a lot more predictable if you're
in the middle you can flip left or flip
right on different
conversations but if you're on the
extremes it's very easy to see what's
going to annoy you what's going to make
you feel like your views are being
confirmed and um
yeah finding out that algorithms were
manipulating us rather than manipulating
the content was probably the scariest
thing i learned from that book
it's interesting i think people think
social medias people think like
instagram and twitter and facebook
are like that now like or they're more
aware of it so they think oh well when i
see posts around like
election time on facebook it's kind of
clouded by that yeah but a lot of people
at least people i talk to think that
google is this kind of fair playing
ground where when i search something i
receive like the same as everybody else
who searches that term and thinks
there's no involvement in
because like you're literally searching
a question a lot of the time right or
like you want to to find some
information and it gives you an answer
and you're like oh well
that's the answer
right there's no assumption that well
there's bias in like my search history
what's going to get me to click the ads
that i see at the top the things that
i've like looked at or not looked at in
the past
google gives you the best answer for you
but that's not necessarily the most true
most true thing that you're or the most
relevant thing for you yeah
and you know for for a while i think
before we realized this we were like oh
we're ranking really well like if you
search propane anything like we come up
on the top page and then we'll like ah
no that's just us
by your own search history of constantly
searching for your own stuff to see how
highly it's ranking yeah exactly whereas
um you know so i i was a big fan of
brave browser i've recently moved back
to safari just just for the seamlessness
but brave have no idea
so yeah exactly
just in time to be able to upload all my
photos
so
brave have their own search engine
similar to duckduckgo it's their own
private search engine and it's similar
user interface to google similar speed
so you don't notice that you're using
something different
but the goal is exactly that
trying to achieve much more of a
objective search result
one of the things that i really loved
about medium when i started using that
was that articles appeared based on
popularity
not based on relevance because a lot of
the time the search terms that you're
putting in are a little bit inaccurate
and i would i would appreciate a version
of google or a version of a search
engine where it was the most popular
that were at the top now obviously that
can be gamed as well through limbic
hijack and
other sorts of games
but
if you were able to crowd source
the points of view that were most viewed
that would give you an interesting
perspective well that's
how the internet originally was and read
it yeah i think reddit has started to
play a bit more of the game now as well
but where you can change the filter so
you can sort by most like most upvoted
top of all time or whatever so the only
problem with something like the reddit
format is that most people will only
scroll down to the the first three third
or fourth page and so anything
that there's a really strong initial
bias where if something gets 10 upvotes
in the first 20 minutes
it's gonna absolutely fly and so you
have to break through the inertia and
then the things which are performing
really well continue to perform well
so it's getting the initial traction
that's a problem that's the same thing
with google right like you've heard the
phrase like i i hit it where someone
will never find it on the second page of
google
like no one ever no one ever scrolls
through the first page and go no no i
don't think i like any of these i'm
going to be on the second page
yeah so like all of the things that do
well
continuously matthew principles occur
everywhere but you see this with youtube
too right like
80 of your plays will come from the 20
top 20 of your videos that you have on
your channel or maybe even more in fact
i would say youtube is the most
algorithmically manipulated platform of
them all like it's just so but the the
price that you pay in terms of it being
so manipulated you benefit in the fact
that i don't have any other social media
where my feed is so right for me
there is always
like so so much three or four things
that i want you to spend an entire day
just watching the next uh related vid
you know the top related video next
recommendation you could just do that
all day it's i'm i'm so long youtube i
just think it's brilliant like if you
think go back like five six years in the
quality of youtube content and now like
it is tv quality production yeah like i
i would sooner go to youtube than
netflix to be honest to find something
interesting
have you gone premium yet i haven't oh
come on i'm trapped in the in in the the
propane account so i'm in use of
infrastructure but you can just pay for
it you can just pay for it and then
you'll both get to use premium
okay
79p
79p if you do through argentina yeah you
need a vpn
google account
well i mean i didn't i paid full price
for it
it's so worth it anyone that hasn't gone
youtube premium
think about how much you value your time
out and you're clicking through
two seven second ad previews every time
you want to watch that video i mean like
but part of that for me is
i like to see i i watch the ads i watch
what people are doing
every time
pretty much yeah wow because you can
infer like the targeting that somebody's
using
you can see the ad creative the
the click the landing page so
you're listening to a master of his
craft you've got to take you got to take
part in the game if you want to you i
want to benefit from the game i'm going
to i'm going to let them
play around i really respect that johnny
like you're you're very
morally consistent with the way that you
see paid advertising i just think like i
don't want to use an ad blocker i don't
like i opt into everything on ios 14 you
know the people who complain about
tracking and then you want more tracking
they they complain about irrelevant
posts on instagram like you're an idiot
like you opted out what do you think
they're gonna do
like it's gonna get worse and worse over
time you're still gonna get ads you're
not turning the ads off you're just
turning off relevant
yeah yeah yeah yeah you remember when we
were watching i can't remember or maybe
in my house watching something on tv on
youtube and this is before i had youtube
premium an ad came up and you said these
[ __ ] idiots here what do they think
they're doing everybody knows that you
shouldn't what you should deselect you
select tv as a placement yeah yeah
because no one's going to click through
onto you can see so if you've ever been
served an ad on youtube like the same ad
like five times in a week that is a big
no no like there should be an impression
cap so you can always spot the you can
spot the noobs
right yeah this i saw a video the other
day about their how much they've spent
on
so
you speak to anybody who likes
and then think about that think about
the number of impressions they've served
absolutely how much should they spend
i it's in i can't remember the number
but it is it is astronomical
do you do either of you two have
grammarly yeah
do you know anyone that does no
interesting
what what is it i like they just check
your grammar on like anything i think on
a browser anything you type into a
browser so it takes all the data that
you type
sends it sends it to apple reads it
and then charges you money for that
privilege
and then goes oh you could have put a
comma there oh thanks yeah it's great
is it 10.99
gentlemen thank you very much for
joining me if people want to find out
what you've got coming up soon with
propane fitness and propane business
where should they go
propanefitness.com forward slash modern
wisdom
that's for people who want to learn how
we do what we do so if you want to build
an online fitness business or an online
business of any kind yourself that's
best place to go
if you just want some macros
propanefitness.com and then just use the
calculator on the main page
and if you want to see what we're up to
youtube.com forward slash propane
fitness we are going
balls in on youtube at the moment and
pumping out some fun stuff
i love it cheers boys thank you see ya
you